你在这十年当中，
你的所谓的付出，
在别人看来是可笑的，
在我们看来也是可笑的，
在你的老公看来是可耻的，
或者说是可恨的。
我今年41岁，
然后呢，
结婚有12年了，
一直都没有孩子，
然后我想问一下，
我现在这个婚姻要不要继续，
因为孩子的原因呢？
其实跟我和我老公身体没有任何的问题，
我们俩身体都是很正常的，
可能问题出现在我这里。
因为我可能对我老公的心理喜欢没有，
就我对他有排斥感哦，
我对他有排斥感的主要原因可能嗯，
是因为我对前任一直没放下，
然后最近呢就有点崩溃，
因为我前任前段时间跟我发信息说他结婚了，
其实这么多年呢，
我一直是在等他的，
然后我现在老公在长，
我现在的老公呢对我特别好，
那他有一个问题就是如果我要买东西吃一个饭呀，
1000多块钱，
或者买个靴子啊，
两三千，
三千四千那都OK，
都可以满足我，
如果我让他给我钱折现的话，
那绝对是不可以的，
我不知道他到底是怎么想的这一点。
我和他持续了这么12年的这个婚姻的原因是家庭，
他所有开支和家庭所有的责任我没有承担，
我过的，
我和他过在一起，
我可能就是比较轻松，
就是就是家庭这块付出的责任我比较轻松，
但是我说实话，
我的内心是非常非常痛苦的，
然后我现在的就是我一直放放不下我前任他现在结婚了，
我也不想去干预别人家庭，
所以我现在特别难受，
我不知道我该怎么办了，
我我问一个问题啊，
就是说你们结婚12年了，
嗯，
家庭的所有的开支都是男方来承担，
以男方对你很大方，
就是给你买东西，
但是不给你的钱啊，
嗯，
然后一直没有孩子，
是你这边主动在弟弟弟对房子是吧，
你弟啊，
不是，
是没有身体接触，
一直你们都没有夫妻的经历的生活，
对这些年一直都没有吗？
没有10年也有八八年没有了，
其实他他可能和我在一起，
其实是也也相当于算是比较轻松的，
为什么呢？
因为可能是因为我他在我心里没位置，
没有那么高，
所以他不管是几点钟回来，
3点回来也好，
四点回来也好，
我都不会去管他，
他比如说去打麻将，
去干什么什事情，
我都不会去过问。
是呢，
其实她过的也是比较那种很轻松的，
我不会去妨碍她任何生活，
那我再问你一个问题啊，
可能这个问题比较隐私一点，
就是说你的丈夫有多少次试图要跟你同房呢？
以前会有，
但是我很排斥，
我很烦，
然后后来就一直没有了，
那你你感觉他在外面有人吗？
我感觉不到，
因为我的心没有在他身上，
所以他有没有对我来说我也无所谓。
其实我坦率的讲啊，
这一段婚姻里面，
我觉得更痛苦的可能是你老公吧，
他可能没有感受到，
因为每个周末可能逛街啊，
或者正常生活啊，
聊天都OK，
但是这些东西都是我伪造出来的，
你看我对他一点都不开心，
不是，
你看你说这个话啊，
你连感知他痛苦的能力都没有，
跟你生活在一起得多痛苦。
我说这句话你认真听，
我再说一遍，
你连感知他痛苦的能力都没有，
那跟你生活在一起，
他得多痛苦。
其实我觉得我很对不起他的，
确确实实实对我挺好的，
在生活上面也很照顾我，
就是我的心，
我也不知道为什么，
就是哎，
这么多年也没有感化到我，
哎，
我现在确确实实好痛苦，
就觉得自己好美，
有又然我问一下你啊，
就是那个你，
你的那个前任，
他比你大多少啦，
7岁，
他7岁，
你当时认识他的时候，
你多大呀？
25，
那当时你们两个人正式的谈过恋爱是不是？
对，
不是为什么原因分开的呢？
他一直不愿意结婚，
但实际上他还是跟别人结婚了，
对不对，
刚结婚。
刚结婚是这样的，
那个女生就是我当时结婚她不愿意，
就是一直在谈朋友，
然后呢，
就是感情也特别好，
就是一直不愿意结婚，
然后我就觉得跟谁结不是结，
我就赌气，
我就跟我现现在的老公结了婚，
然后结了婚之后呢，
陆陆续续其实是有联系的，
他一直都牵着我的心在走，
是有联系的，
所以导致我一直到现在也没有和我老公。
有孩子，
她也是把我害了，
我觉得你当时跟你现在这个老公结婚，
其实你不爱她，
你只是赌气，
对对，
然后她她前段时间她跟我说她已经结婚了，
他说他当我当时结婚的时候，
他说他等我10年，
我当时我就觉得很可笑，
我说我当时要和你结婚的，
说候你不结，
然后我现在有人要和我结婚，
你跟我说你要等我10年，
我觉得真的是好搞笑啊，
然后前段时间他跟我说结婚了，
我不知道是真的是验证了这个十年样，
还是他凑巧想结婚了，
就我觉得搞得像小说一样，
搞得像电视剧一样，
就是有点儿，
我感觉你前任也是很莫名其妙的，
嗯，
你们三个人这关系啊，
就你老公那么痛苦的婚姻，
他居然能坚持12年，
他也很莫名其妙，
你们3个人可真是凑一堆了，
就是你们3个人是不是都是看那种苦奇的偶像剧看多了凑一堆了，
我不是知道我的前任他结婚了嘛，
然后还有小孩了，
就可能那个小孩刚刚出生吧，
我也是才知道的，
嗯，
然后我就想，
哎呀，
算了，
我这么多年是吧，
为他付出这么多是吧？
那最后得到结果是他和别人结婚了，
不行，
我知道这个消息了，
我就去医院了，
你去医院他嘛，
我去医院就检查，
因为我每年都去检查我自己的身体。
就是看我的机能啊什么的都会不会退款，
然后医生告诉我，
他说你现在的数值就是你检查的数据，
数值是30~34岁之间的数据就是非常好，
就还是希望我有一个小孩，
我知道这个事之后呢，
我去做排卵监测，
然后医生就同医生就告诉我哪天哪天可以同房，
然后那天哎，
我也是鼓起勇气跟我老公说，
我就说医生跟我说，
他说嗯，
如果想要小孩的话是吧，
就什么时候什么时候偷房，
结果老公。
拒绝我，
我觉得很喜剧，
所以我就我就我这个没有办法了，
问一个问题啊，
你觉得你为他付出这么多，
你为你的前任付出了什么呢？
就是没有接触过老公，
我觉得都是我承认的关系，
你认为你，
你认为你在合法的婚姻当中，
拒绝跟你的老公发生亲密的关系，
是你对前任的一种付出啊，
可能就是不甘心吧，
就是因为是因为他这个人的存在，
所以我导致我现在这种不平衡的心理。
那我问你一个问题啊，
你觉得你的前任会在这10年当中不碰别的女人吗？
没有，
我知道他陆陆续续都有不停的女人跟他在一起，
那你这守身如玉的意义和价值在哪里呢？
所以说我觉得我自己很傻，
我就想想你把我骂骂醒了，
真的，
我觉得是这样的姑娘，
你呢，
其实把自己深深的演成了一个苦情剧的女主角，
你把自己演成了这样，
这一切都不应该归因于前任，
也不应该归因于现任，
所有的东西归因于你想演一个什么样的人，
你想演一个什么样的角色，
你做的这一切都不能归因于任何人，
只能归因于你给自己设定了一个角色。
你在这10年当中你的所谓的付出，
在别人看来是可笑的，
在我们看来也是可笑的，
在你的老公看来是可耻的，
或者说是可恨的。
嗯，
我认为你的老公或多或少现在也是有一种陷入执念的状态了，
他不知道他该爱你还是恨你，
那么我到底现在还需不需要和我老公在一起，
就我觉得我也不想害他，
但是你的这个老公，
他如果还想跟你在一起，
他如果是一个正常的健康的男士，
你们咋说呢？
因为从我这个角度来说的话，
我觉得你老公这十几年没有这种关系，
这件事儿本身他要么就是也已经出现一种病状了，
心理上。
出现一种病状了，
要么就是你老公可能在外面也有人了，
他为什么选，
为什么拒绝你生孩子这个事儿呢？
他表面上没有拒绝，
所以我说让你去医院检查啊，
身体啊，
OK,
都可以配合，
都可以答应你，
但是实质上就没有实质上的承么，
我问一下你自己是有工作有收入的是吧，
经济条件是可以的是吧，
娘家经济条件也很好是不是？
嗯，
条件的话，
对于我们这个城市来说算是可以吧，
自己存款可能有200吧，
然后，
但是我和我老公可能在经济上相互都不透明，
就是他可能不会告诉我他有多少钱，
然后我这边的收入他可能也不知道，
是这样的，
我觉得你要不要生孩子这个事情啊，
就一定是你先把自己的这个角色改了，
就是我是我生命的第一种导演，
我想让我演什么样的角色，
我自己能说了算，
先把自己的这个角色定位改掉。
不能再沉浸于一个苦情的女主角，
执着于情情爱的女主角的这样一个状态，
至于说要不要跟现在这个老公生孩子，
我觉得你要去把自己抽离出来，
客观的去评价一下这个老公还爱你吗？
还是说她跟你现在生活在一起变成了一种习惯，
或者说他也变成了一种执念，
他就想看你什么时候后悔，
他就想看你什么时候哭着跟他说对不起，
他就想看你什么时候能够匍匐在他面前说这辈子害了他，
我跟你讲也也存在这种可能性的哦，
就就说这男的他心里到底是咋想的，
你要把自己抽离出来，
像一个看客一样去分析，
他到底是还爱你，
还是因为他已经恨你了，
他就想看你的结局。
那我还问一下吴医生，
就是因为我和我老公现在呢，
嗯，
是处于离婚状态，
当时因为是为了买房子，
然后呢，
房子名字写的是我的名字，
但是贷款呢，
一直是他在还，
我们现在有两套房，
一套房是现在住着一套，
然后另外一套房刚装好还没有搬进去，
就是如果我真的想和他分开的话，
嗯，
写我的名字的那套房最后归属于谁呢？
两套房是不是都写了你的名儿啊？
呃，
有一套房是他的名字，
有一套房是我的名字，
但是呢，
所有贷款都是他在还，
一直都是他在承担啊，
我觉得这个事情啊，
第一你在这个婚姻当中，
你这十几年了，
没有履行过妻子的义务，
对吧？
第二，
你们没有共同生育子女，
那第三在这些年人家也是承担家里面的主要的开支，
并且人家对你也不错，
所以在经济上不要让人家吃亏，
如果说一直是人家出的钱，
是人家买的东西，
咱们分手的时候该退就退给人家，
不然的话容易出现嗯事件的，
明白了，
嗯，
好吧，
就这样啊。
好好谢谢那位师，
像刚才这个姐妹，
她的这个情况，
其实在现实生活中她并不少见，
就是有的女孩子，
她可能啊，
第一回谈恋爱就遇到了一个梦中情人一样的，
遇到了一个就是太惊艳的角色，
然后他在以后的岁月当中，
他可能很难走出来，
就老是想着对吧，
你前任老是觉得跟前任在一起，
好像是在拍偶像剧一样，
跟前任在一起的画面每一帧都那么的美好，
空气里都是幸福的灰尘，
然后。
就很难走出来，
这样的人其实大有人在，
我菲姐，
我也就是认真总结过，
说我自己现在日子为什么过得挺好的，
很幸福，
每天都很幸福，
就是因为我很小很小的时候，
我就明白了一个道理，
我绝不拿现任的缺点去跟前任的优点去做比较，
老娘，
我就只看现任的优点，
否则的话，
你老是想着前任的好，
前任这么好，
你俩为什么分手呢？
你俩分手不就是不合适吗？
要么就是人家对吧瞧不上咱吗？
他都瞧不咱了，
他那些优点算个屁呀，
这个逻辑怎么样？
这个逻辑你们记住了啊，
那之所以成为前任，
那肯定就是有很多你不喜欢的地方，
对不对？
那都成为前任了，
要么就是人家没看上咱，
不想跟咱好了，
他不想跟我好就是最大的缺点，
其他的优点都在他弟呀。